hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game uh from round nine of
this year's Tata steel chess tournament
it is n abdat versus yordan F Forest
both of them uh very well known in the
Tata Steel Community and both of them we
could say Rivals already or even within
the Tata Steel Community as um of course
Notre abdat last year Anish giri won
first place but Notre tied with Magnus
carsson uh for second place with eight
points and each one sold first with
eight and a half points but it was
yordan F forz who defeated NRE Beck in
the final round of last year's Tata
still tournament and Jordan also was a
champion of Tata still himself in 2021
uh so it's uh it's definitely a great
fight Jordan would very much like to
repeat his success at uh winning first
place in tata steel and Norbeck will
will definitely try to exact his revenge
for for last year in the final round um
towards the Jordan so let's see what
happened in this one really a wild game
uh all already uh a decisive error has
been made on move 10 and you guys will
have one of the most difficult pause the
video moments that you have ever seen so
let's check it out Notre backck with the
white pieces opens with E4 we have Pawn
to E5 by Jordan Knight to F3 Knight to
C6 and Bishop to C4 the Italian game is
on the board Knight to F6 the two
knights defense but now not Knight G5
like in the prag game uh Pon to D3 the
modern Bishop's opening and here uh okay
a lot of moves can be played you can
play A6 a H6 top moves are Bishop to E7
Bishop to C7 but Yan goes for the
immediate Pawn to D5 and it's okay you
can play it but on the absolute um top
level it is very rare and okay e
captures on D5 Knight captures we have
castles and Bishop to E7 Rook to E1
putting pressure on that E5 Pawn uh and
here just Pawn to F6 defending the uh E5
Pawn which means that this bishop will
be a problem or could be a problem for
the black king if you are ever hoping to
cast Castle or it also just means that
Jordan will develop the bishop the queen
and Castle Queen side so let's see what
happened here uh there is a game and I
believe this is one of the reasons why
maybe uh Jordan uh tried playing this
game is that Jordan already played this
game however he had the white pieces he
played it in
2022 against Arjun Nigi and their game
ended in a draw and in that game Jordan
continued with Pawn to D4 but here NRE
goes Bishop to B3 and it is now already
as of move eight that we have a
completely new game and if you remember
in the beginning of the video I said
that we will have a huge error on move
10 that means completely new game on
move eight and a huge error on move 10
but let's see how that happened uh how
the error happened we have Pawn to A5 of
course you would very much enjoy playing
Pawn to A4 and getting rid of this um
Bishop so you can finally maybe Castle
uh Pawn to C3 of course makes perfect
sense and now Knight to B6 again A4 will
be played nothing spectacular here uh
and here we have Knight to H4 a very
very tricky move and um it's not easy to
to figure out how to deal with this the
threat of course his Queen to H5 check
black will not be able to play G6
because you will capture on G6 with the
Knight and then of course H captures is
impossible because Queen will capture
Rook so that's the the threat here but
how to you uh how to how to play this
position well you either play Pawn to A4
right away and this is a crucial move to
even play this position with black or
you go for this queen que to D7 but
unless you know this line you're not
going to find it over the board uh point
is that now Queen to H5 although one of
the top moves recommended by the engine
doesn't really do all that much you're
just going to play King to d8 uh and
your king is very very happy here and
now if um for example Pawn to A4 uh okay
you've stopped Pawn to A4 by black but
now comes Queen to G4 and already Queens
get traded off for example captures
captures and the game continues nothing
spectacular happening here however in
the game after KN h H4 it seems that
Jordan either mixed his lines or or
maybe he never even saw this position
but he played Pawn to G6 he actively
stopped Queen to H5 from happening and
this is a grave mistake uh but I'm not
going to tell you why feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best move for white uh while I give you
a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on paying
attention to what I've been saying and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Pawn to A4 uh beautiful
beautiful positional uh idea stopping A4
from black which means that this bishop
will remain here for as long as white
once and also you've played Knight A5 uh
you've played A5 so you don't have the
option of going Knight to A5 to further
harass the bishop so how is Jordan to
develop his pieces now uh let's try to
figure out a way in the game Bishop to
D6 was played but uh okay let's let's
try and play something F5 looks like a
very active idea Knight F3 going after
the pawn so okay you can defend the pawn
bishop to F6 or Bishop D6 doesn't really
matter uh you're going to play Knight to
A3 the Knight is now coming to B5 and
there's no real way for you to develop
for example you play Queen to E7 with
the idea okay I'll just play Bishop to
E6 eliminate the bishop Castle Queen
side life is good not so fast Knight to
B5 and now you don't have a move you you
don't have a move on the entire board
uh you can't play Bishop to E6 uh
because white can just trade and then
Knight captures on C7 with check wins
the game you cannot play Bishop to D7
because then the queen no longer guards
the C7 Pawn Knight captures and C7 check
again wins the game so this is uh
pointless so the the you you can't play
something like this you can't Castle
King side the bishop is too powerful uh
you cannot develop the bishop how do you
develop the bishop you can play Bishop
to D7 but then your queen is just Hamm
in how do you how do you develop the
queen so Jordan figured he'd Play Bishop
to D6 and now of course the blacking is
in the center of the board uh Notre Beck
strikes with Pawn to D4 we have Queen to
E7 now Bishop to E3 not rushing anything
because you don't need to rush anything
uh Bishop to D7 and now D captures on E5
F captures on E5 and now Knight back to
F3 so what do you play now it seems like
maybe castling Queen side is uh is
possible here and well it is possible
again not much to look at Knights to G5
is coming and all sorts of nasty threats
on the board like Knight to F7 just goes
after everything and even if you stop
that let's say you go something like
Rook to f8 then comes Knight to E4 and
uh again bad really bad position for
black uh not not much to to to look for
here what what can you play also Bishop
to G5 will be extremely annoying going
after that black queen look at all of
these Square squares covered the bishop
cover covers this diagonal uh it will be
a a positional cramping Masterpiece uh
so instead H6 was played uh but it
doesn't help Knight B to D2 We have
Queens side castles and now Knight to E4
okay you've you've successfully castled
but still how do you how do you play
this bishop to F5 now comes Knight F to
D2 uh Knight to D7 now comes Bishop to
D5 just with the threat of Bishop
captures Knight and then uh Black's
Queen inside is completely ruined the
queen can easily join the attack and
here if you go Knight C to B8 then
Knight to C4 just goes after the A5 pawn
and what do you play here okay you can
trade once here for example captures
captures and B6 but then Queen to D5 and
uh yeah this is pretty much resigns time
so instead after Bishop D5 Knight to C5
was played inviting Bishop captures and
C6 uh but now Notre backck doesn't rush
it he just plays Queen to E2 he knows
that he will always be able to play this
but he wants to have
uh the queen on this diagonal ready
after he kicks away the Knight with Pawn
to B4 so Knight to B8 stopping the
capture now Rook a to D1 we have Knight
B to A6 uh and of course now Knight
captures on D6 eliminating the bishop C
captures and now Knight to C4 again just
going after that A5 A5 pawn queen to C7
defending and here Notre played Queen to
D2 and he was in this position on move
24 uh with equ material on the board
that Jordan fforest resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
also not had like an hour on the clock
some 58 minutes and the Jordan was
already down to 15 minutes on the clock
uh so it seems like definitely a
premature resignation uh especially with
equal material on the board I mean of
course you can always hope that your
opponent makes a mistake uh but I guess
Jordan just figured no that this is
completely unplayable and I will show
you uh why it's completely unplayable
what do you play here with black okay
you could go after the White Queen you
could play something like Knight to E4
or Knight to B3 this is even the top
move recommended by the engine so let's
say let's say as of this moment that
Jordan plays all the top moves
recommended by the engine uh how how can
you how can you beat it okay Queen E2
you just move the move the queen nothing
happening there and you can even
activate the Knight but now you start
going after that weak King side the B5
square is yours okay Bishop to D7 black
can stop this you eliminate some
material from the board Bishop captures
Knight captures now Knight to B5 and
okay here you have to trade Bishop
captures Queen captures you are
attacking the Knight so what's with the
Knight here uh the Knight has to go back
Knight to C5 now you play Pawn to B4 and
it's all about this Pawn to B4 move
pretty much however black plays it
Knight to D7 Now Pawn to H3 you create
some breathing room for the white king
before you continue the attack let's say
Rook H to f8 B captures on A5 and after
something like Knight to C5 5 you will
play Rook to D5 and all of the tactics
now work in White's
favor uh this is uh this is game over
for example Queen to C6 you can even
play Rook captures on D6 and that's it
okay Rook captures on D6 you will play
Bishop captures on C5 nicely connect
with the Rooks and it doesn't matter if
Queens get traded off or not probably
they would king to D7 you will eliminate
the The Rook here King Capt Now Pawn to
A6 you're up two Pawns of course
completely winning uh but this is uh
like I said only if Jordan plays the
absolute best top engine move uh in any
given position which is extremely hard
to do when you know you're loss when you
know your your possession is so bad that
you would uh just resign which Jordan
did uh you know if your possession is
good you will make the effort you will
you will look for moves you will waste
time and another thing ordan was already
down to 15 minutes on the clock and he
needed to make 14 more moves to reach
time control so he just I I'm positive
that he was so disgusted with this
position that he said all right now
let's not play this good game your
revenge was served um you know very
called good sir uh I resign uh so yeah
very nicely done by nck and I don't know
if all of the games have been finished
from this round let me just check
quickly if they have okay so all of the
games have finished so I will now
mention what happened in round nine if
you guys don't want anything spoil don't
watch the video anymore so donchenko
defeated alera fua it was a it was
really wild game and if I if I manage
the time I will definitely show it Ding
and danish Drew their game fairly
quickly gesh and vit also Drew their
game uh maulu defeated Max vadam and I
think it was actually Max who was
playing for the win the entire game I
have no idea what happened there in the
end Abdu satro defeated Jordan like
we've seen here Wei defeated Yan pish it
was also a crazy game so I will probably
have to choose between Wei nepo and
donchenko ala fu if you have uh
preferences do you know do use hashtag
suggestion in the comments and pregara
defeated juun if you haven't seen it the
previous video that I made also uh you
know definitely want to check out uh but
yeah Queen to D2 like I said 24 moves
equal material resignation uh followed
uh definitely not premature uh Jordan
respects Notre Beck enough to to resign
in this position in on 24 moves you know
some of the older players they they
would probably be like I don't want to
you know be everywhere online that I
lost in a miniature but not Jordan he is
the the one of the heroes of ion and he
uh you know doesn't mind uh such things
so once again hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Len Herbert Yun
young an anonymous person ul and
Christopher and Ruth burette for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
day